>>Come and get a card,
come and get a card.
>>Narrator: These students
from the Rocky Mountain School
of Expeditionary Learning in Denver
are voluntarily trading their
privileged status as Americans
for a night to cast their lot
with the less fortunate of the world.
>>Thailand.
>>I'm really excited.
>>What if you get in Thailand?
>>Narrator: Part National
Geographic, part Survivor,
this unique learning experience,
the Global Gateway Program,
plays out on the Heifer Ranch
in Perryville, Arkansas.
>>Holly: It's a program that is
designed to help kids really walk
in somebody else's shoes.
Our program focuses on
hunger and poverty mostly,
a little bit on sustainable
development.
>>Pretend that you're in charge
and they'll follow suit, okay?
>>Narrator: Heifer International
is best known as a nonprofit
that promotes sustainable
development by donating livestock
to impoverished families
around the world.
It also raises awareness
about hunger and poverty
through educational
programs like Global Gateway.
>>Woman: So once you guys have had a
chance to look around, you guys can--
>>Narrator: Shortly after
they arrive here, the students
and teachers get a tour of what
will be their home for the night.
>>Are those two the shacks?
>>They're not shacks,
those are homes.
>>Narrator: Spread over
five acres of the ranch,
the global village
features structures
that represent living
conditions in Guatemala.
>>Boy: This house has solar
paneled lights on the ceiling.
>>Narrator: Thailand, and Zambia,
as well as a generic urban slum
Appalachia, and refugee camp.
>>Holly: Now if they get chosen
to live in the refugee camp,
not only can you not speak English
or any other language to anybody else
in the village, but you also
don't have a place to have a fire.
>>Narrator: At each
stop, students read a bit
about the living conditions
in the various countries.
>>Student: Wood, thatch
and other materials
which can be easily
found in the forest.
>>Narrator: They also discuss issues
like sanitation, poverty and hunger.
>>Holly: Give me a description
of what you think a
hungry person looks like.
>>Student: Probably really weak and
probably can't do a lot of things.
>>Narrator: It's one thing to
talk about hunger and poverty
and quite another to live it.
And just before sunset,
the students brace
for a night they will long remember.
>>Holly: 'Cause I'm gonna call some
numbers, I need you to please come
to the front of the room.
Number twenty-nine.
>>Narrator: As their
numbers are called, students
and one adult chaperone are
combined to form a family,
and assigned sleeping
quarters for the night.
>>Holly: Okay, you visit these folks
tonight, if you want to make soup,
because they have all
the water rights.
So say hello to Guatemala.
>>I love my life.
>>Narrator: While the
lucky inhabitants
of Guatemala will have all the water
they need, they will have to bargain
with their neighbors in
the Appalachian village
for the wood they'll
need to make a fire.
>>Holly: Number eighty-two.
>>Narrator: Each family
receives a bucket of resources
which might include matches,
flashlights, dishes or raw food,
but no one will have everything
they need for the night.
And the refugees will have nothing.
>>Holly: Everybody else who's in
there needs to feel really lucky,
because this is going to be
our refugee family tonight.
>>Narrator: To further
complicate matters,
one member of each family
becomes instantly pregnant.
>>It's a water balloon?
>>Yep.
>>Narrator: Another suddenly
loses the use of one arm.
>>The last time I see my hand.
>>Narrator: As night falls,
and the temperature plummets,
the scramble for food
and resources is on.
>>Hey, do you guys know
how to build a fire?
>>Okay, you guys are--
if this is gonna work,
we really need to cooperate.
>>Okay, How to make--
>>Be quiet, Jonah.
>>A cook fire, okay?
>>Claire: We had to cook our
food, which was, I think,
one of the big challenges
for our group,
because we in the beginning
really didn't know how
to communicate to each other.
We had to stop arguing and we were
like, we need to be able to fix this.
>>He wants-- what do you want?
>>Powdered milk and water.
>>Student: He wants-- no, that's
a small carrot, by the way.
Are you trading that to us?
>>He has nothing to
trade, he's a refugee.
He doesn't have anything.
>>What is he asking for?
>>We have powdered milk.
>>Powdered milk.
>>How do you know?
>>'Cause he's pregnant, and
he's going "Ooh, ooh, ah, ah."
>>And he's a refugee,
so he doesn't have--
>>Narrator: The adults in each
family can decide whether they want
to play the role of the elder, or
as in this case, a two year old.
>>Oh, no, no, no, not there.
>>Holly: One of the things we
talk about with the adults is,
if they step back,
the kids will step up.
Another way of talking about
that is failing forward.
The things that we learn best as
people are lesson that we've had
to learn kind of the hard way.
>>Can't believe you just did that.
>>Do we have anything we
can trade for more firewood?
>>Narrator: Throughout the
evening, negotiations proceed.
>>Do you have any extra
food, any kind?
>>No, we don't.
>>I don't think so.
>>She needs food, Stop calling.
>>Narrator: Conflicts arise.
>>Stop.
>>Hey, guys, we need--
>>Narrator: And alliances are formed.
>>They're gonna give us
food if we cook for them,
but whoever doesn't cook
for them doesn't get food.
>>Marlon: I ended up as a refugee.
We didn't have any supplies like
some other kids, so we had to go
around begging without speaking, or
without speaking the same language.
What ended up happening is, the urban
kids, they shared their food with us.
That was really nice.
It was funny, 'cause they
didn't have any food at all,
like barely any food
to start out with, so.
>>Student: Hey, cooking people,
tell me how you like this idea.
We're gonna boil the--
>>Zak: It was really cool, just being
to work together to get your food
and make sure everybody gets fed.
And I think the highlight of
it was just being independent.
>>This is way better than
what the other people have.
>>Zak: I know, this is ten times
better than what people really have.
They don't start out with rice.
>>Narrator: In the morning, as
the class enjoys a meager meal,
they begin to share their
thoughts about the experience.
>>Marlon: I still knew
in the back of my mind
that I was gonna get food tomorrow,
but I think if I really was poor,
that I wouldn't know that and
I think it would be a totally
different experience.
>>Holly: I just heard kids
last night going to bed,
"This is really hard,
but it's really good.
This is really helping
me think about things.
This is making me think
about people who are hungry
or the different choices or
where people sleep in the world."
>>Narrator: After breakfast,
there are chores to tend to,
like preparing wood for
the next group of villagers
and feeding some of the farm animals.
>>Open the door, we're
coming through.
>>Narrator: During a
structured time for reflection,
students perform skits about some
memorable moments of the experience,
like when the Guatemalan
villagers refused to give
out water unless the others
washed and cleaned for them.
>>We need water.
>>Why?
>>We need breakfast.
>>No, clean our dishes and our
house and we'll give you water.
>>Well, we need-- we have to cook--
>>You shouldn't have
forced us to make--
>>Well, you know what, we have
an unlimited supply of water
and you guys have nothing,
so clean our house.
>>Holly: As a teacher, I'm often
trying to pose big questions.
How do we solve this problem?
How do we grapple with this dilemma?
And so it couldn't
have been any better
that Guatemala decided they weren't
giving water out this morning.
It truly allowed us to come to
a place where we had to wrestle
and grapple with some choice.
>>Aly: They ended up giving us
water, but not very happily,
so that was really
hard, because I felt
like they were being very
selfish, because they could,
would make everyone else hungry and
make everyone else upset and just
so they didn't have
to do their dishes.
>>No, but it tastes burned.
>>Aly: This experience really opened
my eyes to like how people truly live
out of the comfort zone, and
this past twenty-four hours,
I got to live like they lived
and understand why I need
to be taking action in my community
and I hope everyone
else took that away.
>>Narrator: Heifer has added three
more facilities around the country
where students can experience
the Global Gateway program.
There are also classroom
initiatives like Read to Feed,
a third through sixth
grade reading program
that highlights different cultures
and animals around the world,
and a standards based curriculum
for grades six through eight.
It shows how US consumer
choices affect others.
But for making a lasting impression,
nothing beats living the lesson.
>>Wait, where's the firewood.
>>Give us a carrot.
>>Jonah, move; Where's the firewood?
>>Holly: It's not just, "Wow, we had
a great experience and now we go home
and turn on our lights and
go about our daily business
and not think about this again."
It's meant to affect people to
think, "Okay, what can I do?
I have the power and the
choice to make a new decision,
because I have new knowledge,
so what is that choice
or decision going to be?"
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.